naveen why did you unmatch me
it's me ben affleck just went viral on
tick tock
after an influencer shared a video that
the actor allegedly sent her on a dating
app
oh my god here's what went down
influencer naveen jay
recently shared this clip on tick tock
that's naveen
looking totally bummed out explaining
that she unmatched what she thought was
a fake ben affleck account on the
exclusive dating app
raya
thinking about so many things i just
wish things would get
better i'm trying to get rid of them
well
that's when she claims the 48 year old
oscar winner sent her a video message
on instagram naveen why did you unmatch
me
it's me she captioned the clip quote
sorry ben i am completely shocked i had
no idea
so it's unclear exactly when the alleged
exchange took
place and ben he hasn't publicly
commented on the post
but back in 2019 the justice league star
did confirm he was on raya in a clever
way
after the news broke of his alleged
involvement with the dating app
he used all the attention to support a
cause close to his heart
posting this pic on instagram alongside
the caption
ha you got me i'm dating and asking raya
to support the organization the midnight
mission
who knows i'm making trouble always
forgiven right when it comes to ben's
love life
he was most recently dating actress anna
de armas
but they split in january after a year
together
and just last week the a-list actor made
headlines for spending time with his
ex-fiance
jennifer lopez following her split from
alex rodriguez
it's an added bonus to find somebody you
know that
was such a good friend i thought to
myself this person would be my friend
you know and you don't find that every
day either so uh it's a very special
thing for both of us
but a source previously told et the two
are just
pals quote they obviously have a
romantic history but at this point
they only have a friendship they both
admire each other professionally
respect one another and feel comfortable
with each other
as for ben's ex-wife and mother of his
three kids
jennifer garner she's not concerned with
ben's recent reconnection with jlo
a second source tells et quote jen isn't
bothered by ben hanging out with j-lo
or anyone else she wants what is best
for ben
the source adds that the 49 year old
actress has other priorities when it
comes to her ex
quote what matters most to her is ben
being a great dad
they've been in a good groove when it
comes to co-parenting for a while and
their kids happiness
is jen's main priority
[Music]